from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between mcdonald's in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
hey guys joe from food wars we're doing
a new season we're comparing the u.s to
japan in order to do that i want to
introduce you to co-host and my man in
japan george hello guys i'm george i'm
from japan and i like mcdonald's
[Music]
so in japan our mcdonald's sodas come in
three sizes this is small
small
and this is japan's medium
medium
and this one is japan's large large
in japan our chicken back nuggets come
in 5
and 15 pieces
our chicken mcnuggets come in 4
6
10 20
or 40 piece
look at all those nuggets
oh they've been sitting for a while
japan mcdonald's fries come in three
sizes small
medium and large in the u.s you get your
fries in four sizes kids small
medium and large little guy
look at this little guy
so this is the largest fries and i'm
gonna weight them we are going to also
weigh a large mcdonald's fry
wow
okay so so far our larges are the same
yeah wow that worked perfectly the thing
i just did there great job joe
go home
go
now let's measure the medium
why not
our mediums are smaller
interesting so this is a japanese big
mug
[Music]
so this is a japanese big mac this is an
american big mac and we're gonna weigh
it as well
now we've got a heftier big mac here in
the u.s
it's more like it it's in japan the big
mac value set which is a big mix
and medium fries and a medium drink
comes out to 690 yen or six dollars 21
cents in the u.s that same meal costs
8.54 cents or
948.46 japanese yen that's a
37.52 increase in price in the us
what the heck
so here is everything you can only get
at japan's mcdonald's you cannot get in
the u.s and this is everything you can
get at a u.s mcdonald's that you cannot
get in japan so we're gonna start with
waffle cons right here so we got plain
so plain means it's like rich milk taste
and next one is strawberry strawberry
personally i like this
and next one is
chocolate and almond
right there
it's not melting good job buddy so here
we've got mac flows so much fruits means
there's soda and on top of that there's
ice cream that's it that's it and this
is mac fruits melon
itadakimasu
it's too sweet
this is great
coffee mug floats
and the last one we've got coke mcfloats
oh
joe
you definitely try this
yes absolutely i'm trying that when i go
to japan that looks real good let me
think here hang on a second
okay
we do not have mcfloats here in the u.s
so i'm going to make my own on the way
over here i was looking for grape soda
it's actually harder to find than i
thought phantas is not very popular in
the united states but we got this
this is
midnight grape kickstarter mountain dew
it's grape
[Music]
ha ha left over from the ben and jerry
shoot stuff is frozen there we go
[Music]
yeah
i'm into this
these would do well in the u.s
our cold drinks a little bit different
uh we have two exclusive slushies that
you can't get in japan one is a pink
lemonade strawberry watermelon yeah dude
it looks real good yes they do have
mcflurries and ice cream in japan the
woman flurry you can get in the u.s is
this one an m m's mcflurry
sorry
it's
since melted but it's like those uh
those mini m m's i went to the one of
the few mcdonald's in the country where
the ice cream machine was working hot
caramel sundae and
the classic
fudge sundae
so let's go with soft drinks right here
found the grape
and here is fanta melon
and this one is japanese vegetable juice
and there is
i guess more than 20 or 30 vegetables in
it and it's good for health for sure
itadakimasu
we've got
cool white grape so can become so can we
just like a japanese blended tea
it's healthy and japanese people drink
this on a daily basis so next one we've
got
earl grey iced tea let me show you
wait
there is something
there is a
mosquito i have to make a complaint
japan mcdonald's
next one we've got
oolong tea
so this is not actually japanese tea
it's a chinese tea that's good for
health as well
for health we do have
a mango pineapple smoothie
and a banana strawberry smoothie
smoothies have fruit right
oh yeah
i can just feel the nutrients coursing
through my veins
so let's start with this hawaiian menu
this is limited this one right here is
cheese loco moco
oh it's messy
it's a damn glass sauce
man and it's also got
round egg right there
beef patty and some cheese
i'm hungry actually
oh this is good
oh
this is home to numai which means
really really delicious
first the next one we've got garlic
shrimp and it's also got
interesting bun
there is sesame on there and um deep
fried shrimp
hawaiian barbecue potato and beef
demi-glass sauce again
it's gonna be good
this is called barbecue burger right but
i don't taste burping cattle alright so
next one we've got hawaiian pancake with
triple berry sauce two pancakes
mmm
smells so sweet
let's go
[Music]
too sweet
mac face blue hawaii
wow
it has bright blue color
this is mac face cassis and orange
i will get this i will get this so
congratulations this is the worst
okay
breakfast time this is a breakfast
burrito
neon yellow egg
mexican style salsa
not to be confused with what canadian
salsa
this is actually the same burrito from
the us uk thing we shot over a year ago
so let's go on to these breakfast
sandwiches here japan does have the
mcriddles which are a favorite of mine
so unfortunately we will not be talking
about those today
sad please i love you mcgriddles
so what they don't have and also the uk
did not have were our breakfast biscuit
sandwiches i don't know how to describe
a biscuit other than
it's dry
it's baked
maybe they're made with cornmeal
according to the internet this is not a
scone so there you go sausage egg and
cheese
our egg is like this fluffy folded
scrambled egg egg so there's like sunny
side up ours are scrambled i can tell
this was like folded over you can see
like the fold lines there this is how we
do in the u.s bacon egg and cheese is
there a better breakfast combination in
the world i don't think there is then
they just have the sausage
no egg no cheese just sausage and
biscuit
we have regular sized hot cakes and we
have a hot cake and sausage combo of
course
comes with syrup
and
butter
very natural pose
very natural feeling right now
always up for report yes
breakfast is served
oatmeal on the side to be mixed in
cranberries and raisins and
diced oh
diced apples
and here we've got
mega muffin
pork patties that's huge one
mini pancakes
oh cute
it comes with apple cream sauce
[Music]
oh
this is perfect for breakfast i will get
it
bacon egg muk sandwich
so it's got
bacon
and round egg and cheddar cheese
that's it
and you might be surprised we've got
phil fish
ta-da
so phil fish is on the breakfast menu i
guess japanese people tend to eat fish
for breakfast three exclusive burgers
here in the us are variations on the
quarter pounder with cheese yes we've
all seen pulp fiction we know about the
whole quarter ponder thing does not
exist outside of the u.s i don't think
so probably why they don't have quarter
ponders in japan the classic quarter
pounder with cheese look at this guy i
mean this was maybe my go-to one for
a decade the quarter pounder with cheese
deluxe i don't know
i feel like this is pretty close to a
whopper i'm not a big whopper guy but
there you go
a deluxe quarter pounder with cheese
the double quarter powder with cheese
look at the size of this thing
yes
sir
japan's exclusive burgers teriyaki mac
burger which is my most
favorite one
my body is made of
bacteria butter
[Laughter]
so it's got a mayo right there and
lettuce pork patties dip it into
delicious terry excels and it's covering
whole pork parties perfectly
joe when you come to japan please try
this you will thank me later
everything that they have looks so good
and sounds so good man when i go to
tokyo
first stop i'm going to mcdonald's sushi
ramen get it out of my face i want the
teriyaki burger that's the first thing
i'm getting when i get there
i'm getting full actually
working with food boob
slow down george we got a lot of food to
cover
welcome to food
all right so we've got
bacon lettuce burger right here it looks
sad
egg cheeseburger but we also call it
eguchi eggo cheese is an abbreviation
for egg cheeseburger japanese people
love abbreviation
it's got ketchup and pickle
round egg and cheddar cheese and beef
patties
next one spicy beef burger oh look at
this oh it looks so spicy you spicy mayo
or something like that so here we've got
samurai muk
samurai
samurai mac
yo
that sounds awesome and this blue one is
called
rosted soy sauce double thick beef we've
got
roasted soy sauce bacon tomato thick
beef so if you want a little bit more
like healthy veggies
go for it
uh yeah george i don't know if that
makes that much healthier there because
it also has twice as much meat and
cheese if you're looking to be healthy
at a mcdonald's in japan i'd stick with
the vegetable juice and this one right
here is called
teriyaki chicken filet o wow so much
sauce so next one we've got eb philio
abby means shrimp so it's a shrimp
fillet
oh yeah it's got oral sauce ora sauce is
like a ketchup and mayonnaise
so it's got a lot of shrimp in there
so good so good in the u.s we have about
four uh exclusive chicken sandwiches
specifically i didn't see this on the
menu but apparently you guys don't have
a mcchicken
which is just chicken sandwich uh
regular bun
mayo
chicken
[Music]
yeah
we also have
check this out
spicy mcchicken
so pretty much the same chicken but like
they put spicy coating on the
breading on the chicken every fast food
chain in america right now is having
what we're calling the fried chicken
sandwich wars popeyes
burger king of course mcdonald's all of
them are at this arms race to have the
best chicken sandwich i think cause
chick-fil-a's edged everyone out these
are the three that are currently
available i don't know for how long
there's a crispy chicken sandwich things
as a brioche bun uh pickles
and no sauce which i think is strange
like the whole flavor is just
just the chicken spicy
chicken sandwich same deal but of course
spicy sauce
and the spicy chicken deluxe which to
george's point has more vegetables on it
you know to be healthier
okay so when it comes to side menus
we've got shaka shaka chicken
and we have
two flavors oh
two flavors can you hear that
thunder thunder thunder because it's
raining season in japan
the sunny season here in southern
california
and here is red pepper
and this one is cheddar cheese
[Music]
founder stop
so all you have to do is just put the
powder into the back
and
shake it
and the powder
should be covering the whole shotgun
chicken
big one
like this
this i've seen before this i want that's
the thing i want the most of the
japanese mcdonald's us mcdonald's we
have the bags we have the chicken just
get the spice packets throw one in
we've got
side salad
and it comes with this
roasted sesame dressing let's go
that was cool
now put it all in the garbage we've got
edamame and corn
yogurt
and there's
cow
cow
exclusive sauces it's sauce talk time
sauce talk
we have sweet and sour sauce they gave
me
hot mustard
this would be honey mustard you guys
have hot mustard i know you don't have
honey mustard of course
ranch uh ooh
spicy buffalo
now these might be promotions because of
that uh
singing group bts
but we have right now a
cajun sauce and a sweet chili sauce this
sauce is
fantastic this is the sauce this has to
stay on the money so these two are new
ones
this one right here is
soy sauce based sauce
man this is fantastic good job very good
taste
so this one right here is called
louisiana jostos oh
it does look like very spicy one
[Music]
this is not spicy i don't want actually
we were supposed to have buy burger
options but unfortunately you can only
get them from 5 30 p.m but let me
explain what buy burger is
bai simply means double in japanese so
if you order a normal big mug it has two
big patties right but if you order buy
big mug it has four beef patties but not
only big mac but all burgers and adopts
the buy burger options that's funny you
can only get double the meat after 5 30.
that's really funny that would not stand
in this country at all people would lose
their minds
four
and once a big mac
so after shooting this video i'm gonna
order buy big mug and then buy by health
you ain't gotta tell me george bye
health
all right here are all the ingredients
for u.s big mac oh god the bun it has
enriched flour which is wheat flour
vinegar and contains wheat onto the beef
patty 100 pure usda inspected beef no
fillers no extenders prepared on the
grill with seasoning salt and black
pepper there you go there you go
shredded lettuce ingredients lettuce
nice the big mac sauce ingredients
soybean oil
[Laughter]
extractives of paprika soy lecithin
the pickle slice ingredients cucumbers
water distilled vinegar salt calcium
chloride alum potassium sorbates
preservative natural flavors
polysorbidae extractives of turmeric for
color onion ingredients onions there you
go
few things i want to note alum is used
to dissolve steel
holly's orbit 80 has been linked to
colon cancer and mice cue the dancing
mice
and caramel color is on california's
list of chemicals that may cause cancer
and reproductive toxicity good good
counterpoints they all taste fantastic
so mcdonald's japan doesn't disclose
their ingredients in the big mug however
they do tell us where the ingredients
come from if you order a big mug in
japan you'll eat beef from australia or
new zealand
buns made from wheat imported from the
usa canada and australia
and pickles made from cucumbers grown in
turkey sri lanka or india
onions grown in the usa or india
sliced cheddar cheese made in new
zealand australia the usa or japan
and lettuce grown in japan taiwan the
usa or malaysia
the only ingredients that come from
japan are the cheese and the lettuce
and even then mcdonald's still imports
some lettuce and cheese from other
countries so this is a very
international burger
thank you world
so in japan our big mac is 525 calories
and 28.3 grams of fat
and
1007 milligrams of sodium and 41.8 grams
of carbs and 26 grams of protein in the
us our big mac is
550 calories 30 grams of fat 1010
milligrams of sodium 45 grams of carbs
and 25 grams of protein so the u.s has a
slight increase on everything except
protein so in japan our five piece
nuggets is 270 calories and 17.2 grams
of fat and 506 milligrams of sodium and
13.1 grams of carbs and 15.8 grams of
protein broken down each nugget is 54
calories we don't have a five piece here
in the us but we do have this a ten
piece let's get those stats on the
screen go ahead and divide everything by
two and yes now we have the stats for a
five piece pretty smart eh if we wanna
divide all that by i think five you'll
get the stats for one nugget
this is so exhausting
in japan if you order a big mac meal
with large fries and a medium chocolate
shake the grand total will be
1405 calories and in the u.s adding
medium fries and a medium chocolate
shake to a big mac the grand total is
1660 calories and that is a calorie
increase of 18.14
if you're wondering why we're using a
large fry but a medium chocolate shake
turns out that in japan you can't get a
large chocolate shake the only salty and
medium i'm assuming because i don't want
you eating that much ice cream
hey thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this us versus japan mcdonald's episode
check out our us vs uk mcdonald's
episode right here